what is it that makes the man the man is
it the hormones okay is it if it's the
hormones and
you decide to give yourself a different
cocktail of hormones I'm making this up
by the way I'm not saying it should
happen this way it's a way to start
thinking about it maybe the track Meats
have hormone categories and maybe giving
yourself the wrong hormones is delerious
to your health would you not admit that
so you feel this way because you're
concerned about you're so deeply
concerned about the health of the people
people who are trying to find their
place on the gender Spectrum it's not
something that keeps me up at night but
when the subject comes up I care about
them like I care about all people you
think about all people of course yeah
give Bill actually is saying I do care
about someone who might be young and
confused about their gender or whatever
else but at the same time that doesn't
mean I have to throw out logic and
reason so that we fill them full of
hormones and have them Crush people of
the opposite sex when it comes to sports